hey what is up guys and qHD here and
these are my real first thoughts and
impressions of the new Samsung Galaxy s7
and galaxy s7 edge should be pretty
simple so there are two phones this year
a 5.1 inch galaxy s7 and a 5.5 inch
galaxy s7 edge so no edge plus or any
weird naming these are the only two
phones and they look familiar because
well on the surface they are very
similar to a galaxy s6 we already know
and actually because they're so similar
they've gotten really upstaged by some
other announcements this week like the
LG g5 but Samsung took what was already
a pretty good phone with the galaxy s6
and then fixed most of the worst parts
about it the galaxy s7 is what feels
like a slightly refined improved just
better polished version of its
predecessor so first of all it comes in
four colors this time and actually black
phone not blue so that's cool a gold
platinum a silver titanium and a white
pearl and just overall fit and finish of
the familiar design is a little bit
better they curved the glass on the back
now like they did with the note 5 making
it a little bit easier to hold and it's
now fully ip68 water-resistant with
pretty much no added bulk or flaps or
anything weird like that so no worries
about using your phone in the rain or
near water and can we all just take a
second to appreciate that Samsung
actually just made their new phone one
millimeter thicker to accommodate a
larger battery Thank You Samsung I
haven't been preaching to a brick wall
it is much appreciated also the camera
bump on the back is now greatly reduced
it's not totally flat but it's less of a
pain when the phone is on a table and
the home button slash fingerprint reader
on the front is also more flat so yeah
it just looks and feels in a subtle way
like a smoother slightly refined version
of the s6 kind of like the iPhone 6s was
for the iPhone 6 so I guess you can
think of this as like a galaxy s6 S
which really isn't that bad people are
quick to forget that the galaxy s6 was
one of the best phones of 2015 and in a
lot of ways the galaxy s7 is following
up on that the galaxy s6 had what was
considered by most to be the best
display on any smartphone Samsung
bringing that back with this really
bright quad HD super amoled display here
on the galaxy s7 it also had one of the
best cameras in any smartphone and
Samsung has again improved on this
bringing a new 12 megapixel sensor with
larger pixels a wider F 1.7 aperture and
some pre ridiculously fast autofocus
that I got to play around with now the
camera is again obviously one of those
things that I need to spend more time
with and that I'll be testing thoroughly
for the full review but from my limited
hands-on time it seemed to have some
pretty great poise as a great follow-up
to the s6 and of course top end specs
again so in the US the new Snapdragon
820 chip 4 gigabytes of ram and the
latest version of android and they
brought back the micro SD card slot so
you have expandable storage at your
fingertips again overall it's kind of a
beast now it's obviously not perfect I
mean this thing is still going to be
number one slippery it's still a serious
reflection and fingerprint magnet all
the time and it still has that tiny
speaker at the bottom it still doesn't
have an IR blaster anywhere or even USB
type-c and it's totally still running
the heavily skinned version of Android
that people sometimes love and sometimes
hate but either way it'll be a familiar
experience for anyone who's used a
Samsung smartphone recently so those
bright super saturated colors and big
round colorful icons it is actually a
toned down version compared to previous
versions of the legendary TouchWiz but
yeah there's no escaping the Samsung
look here there's a couple new features
in this software like the always-on
display which will show you the time and
date and battery at all times on that
AMOLED display you can even choose to
have like a calendar show up there or
decide what information is always up and
that barely slips any battery since it's
AMOLED and on the s7 edge there's also
an improved edge panel which gives you
way more options to put stuff over there
you can put your favorite apps you can
put custom tasks which should be really
useful you can also get people and news
but yeah I really like the idea of being
able to swipe in and launch a custom
action within an app like a task for
that tasks panel so that used to be
something you needed a third-party app
from the Play Store to do cool to see
that built in here so overall look this
is a safe bet for Samsung as a phone and
it's going to be a super solid
smartphone my preference between the two
right now is
we going to be the s7 edge just because
of that bigger battery but also I like
bigger phones anyway but yeah if you
were looking for something wild and
radical and crazy
you'll probably gonna want to look
elsewhere maybe keep waiting or go
something like the g5 but Samsung has
stuck to their roots with this one and I
like it can't wait to get it in for the
full review thanks for watching and I'll
talk to you guys in the next one peace